la crise ukrainienne serait-elle une
opportunité pour olafsen de renforcer sa
stature internationale où washington qui
juge en tout cas la position du nouveau
chancelier trop faible vis-à-vis de la
russie à quelques heures de sa rencontre
avec joe biden aujourd'hui le chef du
gouvernement allemand s'est dit prêt à
envoyer des troupes supplémentaires dans
les pays baltes regardez
nous sommes prêts à faire tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour renforcer ceux là
cela vaut également pour la police
aérienne que nous menons actuellement
dans les pays baltes et dans la région
méridionale nous sommes prêts à prendre
des décisions comme vous le savez je
vais encore parlé cette semaine aux
chefs de gouvernement des pays baltes à
leur chef et à ceux qui ont des
responsabilités là bas il est très
important pour moi que nous restions
proches les uns des autres et que nous
nous concertions et que nous ne le
fassions pas par le biais des médias
mais avec nos amis depuis de nombreuses
années le gouvernement fédéral à une
ligne de conduite claire à savoir que
nous ne livrons pas dans des régions en
crise et que nous ne livrons pas non
plus d'armes létales à l'ukraine
les enjeux de ce premier déplacement du
nouveau chancelier allemand aux états
unis tout de suite avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas
jouannet il s'agit du premier
déplacement à washington pour olaf
scholz évidemment il va être grandement
question du dossier ukrainien le
chancelier allemand va sans doute tenter
de rassurer la maison blanche parce
qu'on sait qu'il y a des divergences
entre berlin et washington sur la
réponse à apporter à la situation en
ukraine on sait que le gazoduc north
stream 2 est désormais suspendu à la
situation ukrainienne mais berlin refuse
toujours par exemple de fournir des
armes à l'ukraine alors les deux hommes
joe biden et olaf scholz devraient
discuter spécifiquement de ses sujets et
plus généralement de la coopération
entre leurs deux pays on rappelle que
washington a déployé de nouvelles
troupes en europe et particulièrement en
allemagne et que berlin pourrait
annoncer prochainement le déploiement de
soldats en lituanie alors selon la
presse allemande la maison blanche
pourrait également profité de ce
déplacement pour demander à olaf scholz
de faire preuve de plus de fermeté
contre moscou et au delà de ce dossier
ukrainien c'est un voyage très important
pour le chancelier allemand qui est à la
peine depuis sa prise de fonction les
sujets internationaux ont été quelque
peu reléguées au second plan ce qui lui
vaut un certain nombre de critiques
notamment de la part de position en
allemagne alors en ouvrant cette
séquence internationale qui va donc le
conduire à washington puis à kiev la
semaine suivante olaf scholz espère
sûrement reprendre des couleurs mais on
sait que le positionnement de berlin un
vis-à-vis de la russie ou encore
vis-à-vis de la chine n'est pas
véritablement aligné sur celui de
washington alors on surveillera la
tonalité des échanges entre joe biden et
olaf scholz ce lundi à la maison blanche
pour rappel au mois de juin dernier
anthony blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine avait affirmé que les états
unis n'avaient pas de meilleur ami que
l'allemagne une amitié qui connaîtra un
nouveau test ce lundi